hello everybody and what actor
are you are you doing the intro guys bro
hello Tobias is way higher up everybody
combate this is my skin craft I will
alright mark finish it off man I do
started for you
bye bye oh wait no no that's unsub right
[ __ ] you guys ah alright no do it do it
I won't say a word
it's fun [ __ ] it done that's a
message that's the admit you guys okay
so anyway you see this swath of
devastation here
that's worse but the ending of the last
episode left off I still can't believe
that happened
oh it was cool look at that mountain
there slinky one zombie can we get that
bread cuz I am dying I think we've got
mode on oh wow I got glass out the ass
like everything is glass ass glass
nothing yes remember diamonds who
listened diamond armor but Ariel you
don't have [ __ ] then I got bread did you
guys get bread no funny you go then
hahaha okay so we're gonna actually do
an objective here which is underwater
house I think it's a thank you so much
zombie I think that's what we decided on
right right yeah right okay hang on
first I'm gonna get this iron because we
and khalsa cuz we need to get furnaces
for um we need frozen before oh we have
a bunch of like glass to make glass oh
yeah hold on yeah buckets bucket buckets
but I can't hear you but what
I don't care wait are you talking to
someone yeah my father's yelling at me
it's professional my crafting you tell
him dit what is a sponge do I have a
sponge I have a sponge - I don't know a
sponge does I'm gonna soak up the ocean
this is the profession how does it work
like that
I would assume why the hell else would
we have a sponge I don't know I don't
even know where you get sponge I'm just
lucky an ocean I'm just getting the iron
so that we can all squiddy spammin
squiddy's famine whose did someone's try
to teleport to me why I don't know I
didn't see who it was
tofu [ __ ] off long cat 1996 denied
teleports you got it bud yeah I shall
unobtainable this but where the hell are
you guys we're in the cavern hitting
some iron I'm getting coal and iron iron
buckets iron I've got twenty seven iron
bud that's probably enough you know bud
wow I totally like went a little gay
there for a second what just we did I
hear that I was all that's probably
enough no we didn't pick up on that at
all
oh it comes out sometimes it's super
cereal
everybody what oh well that's offensive
if you're with Al Gore is that someone
you guys have you do the butters what do
the butters you do the butters - you
know that what I mean you know what
we're talking about there's only one way
to do the butter you guys are forcing my
hand here I was gonna save it for
something awesome we've already heard it
once hey hey
haven't have heard in the intro I need a
table you know what I could talk it to
the table a table out here Tama Mike
you're so demanding I wouldn't give you
anything crafting table
where are you guys at standing on top of
the mountain doing nothing
Thank You zombie hey and he gave me
buckets too so I don't need I don't need
it anymore I'm gonna fish my house at us
holes tried to blow up can eyes I think
hold the phone I didn't blow up anything
you're still an [ __ ] zombie can I
have tea I can't argue with that how do
you know oooh I don't want to go down
there
zombie I need ammo up his house thank
you very much
and those Agha don't wanna peel the
housing until I need flint and steel
please yes thing we need to build a
glass house not blow up old houses
please thank you I'll be Flint thank you
thank you so much Carrie where are you
started on the new house looking for you
I'm right here
oh ok where's the house it doesn't exist
oh this is it oh that's it you killed it
so I'm gonna kill myself I've got tons
of coal can we go side by stand oh [ __ ]
I actually killed myself and I'm gonna
blow up a [ __ ] it I fell I'm sorry
silent diamond at the bottom I got
really excited and killed myself a
little bit you went off a little early
you got so excited that won't happen so
mark has that problem a lot shut up no I
don't I do not he totally does I do not
I currently cannot get out of the water
that I'm trapped in that's good mark has
a condition and everyone should
subscribe to feel sorry for his
collision are you dying about hey
subscribe cuz art there's nothing wrong
with premature Nastase to subscribe
because I'm so awesome you don't even
know ok
no one's subscribed because you're
awesome they subscribe because you
scream like a girl and because they feel
sorry for you yeah actually that seems
pretty accurate that that pretty much
explains everything I've ever done
everyone knows Lorde minions the awesome
one who knows the Lord manias sucks 10
[ __ ] in a row I'm talented not that a
row ah
I'm dark it's dark what's going on it's
probably nighttime no I felt I got like
in a hole I'm trying to go towards here
we go
what death
I have 47 iron in like 80 coal okay for
some reason I can't get towards this TNT
something's blocking me from the T add a
zombie block him from the TNT I'm trying
to get to the Tod he does not mean gonna
build a glass house [ __ ] the glass house
glass house - I've been stocking up the
buildings glass house and mark just try
to destroy everybody well Bob killed him
so so he lost his glass oh come on
alright fine but we can go someplace
with sand I've got plenty of coal to
make but fine I'm getting like we got a
bunch of glass hey let's go back that
shadow biome where we were right on the
water with oh [ __ ] that there's water
right over there right over there coming
I'm in a giant pit I can't see anything
out of there come over here I'm right
behind you where I'm aware come with me
Oh every day I see it it's like an
enormous ocean of more beer and dude
that sounds awesome normos ocean of more
beer ah Oh lick which I'm gonna need to
finish this drink soon finish it well oh
yeah but I guess I got no reason not to
oh okay so we got our giant ocean here
and we got glass so let's do something
about oh I don't have any food do you
guys have food yeah I do but about sixty
bread can I have like two of those yeah
where are you killing a zombie by mark
all right Oh creeper oh that's not mark
that's you oh this sponge does soak it
up that's awesome
we're yeah man yeah I knew right behind
you sponges most fearsome on the ground
guys this sponge is like awesome spot
what the hell what are we doing just
place a sponge it like I never really
support weird it releases
I got sponges how do you place it you
just right click yeah douche nozzle then
what then it oh no [ __ ] holy [ __ ] on now
what do I do
break it like what are we gonna do with
you guys no no wait come here look watch
this Wow what
oh dude we're soaking up water exactly
all right I'm gonna start the foundation
of the Glass House zombie is existed
thank you I don't either
what [ __ ] you what I didn't say anything
what huh okay
ah wha huh wha shut up
I can uninvite you to this drug oh [ __ ]
it got really dark and I'm a bit
uninvited but you can't undream cus very
true Wade this is a factual statement
that you just said I did I full of facts
all you you albino spider piece of crap
zombie can we get torches torches blazed
yes ma'am I will ears ever shot up weird
efficient zombie can you find me a job
you have a job ah yeah but it's a John
Grisham novel it's exhausting you didn't
even tell the audience what that is all
about well I work in a law firm and uh
wait what happened to the school okay
shut the [ __ ] up
wait what awesome what I would be able
awesome awesome before ah working at a
schools not awesome kind of this torches
everywhere by the way this doesn't seem
physically possible but could be a
professional women's mud wrestler free
like me yeah we do it's pretty awesome
he doesn't even let me get in for free
but it's okay though you're in next time
yeah I know you always say that you
always say next time but I'm never in
our line
well I'm sorry next time you always keep
coming back for more so how far down are
you going I don't know let's go all the
way down suck it
yeah you too doing what something you
guys what time go it all the way down
what does it sound like we're doing
I don't like time without me huh huh
what what oh no no the water came back
yeah it's doing that we should probably
start building things yeah we're gonna
drown in a really weird way Glass House
yeah okay um [ __ ] it ah ah but hey shut
up I'm I hate glad I did this once and
it was terrible and I I swore I'd never
do it again so I don't know why we're
doing it again I don't know I've built
three furnaces I'm gonna start making
glass we already have glass when did we
get gloves we have up T million glass
well we're getting more why cuz no one
told me we had glass we if I did I was
too drunk to listen well you're not that
drunk
you're not that drunk I'm not I have no
one's not a drunk
oh [ __ ] there's water in here what the
[ __ ] did you do Bob I'm hot anything
Bobby you son of a [ __ ] but no wife and
I've got no Sandin oh [ __ ] mark we need
a roof really bad
shut up him get in there did somebody
give me some glass
no no zombie could I get some glass
Oh zombie oh listen to mark he's he's
too drunk no I'm not drunk at all he's
really making bad decisions right now
zombie zombie don't do it I will leave
your server I will tell everyone that I
hate it
no he won't I totally will he loves you
too much you won't find anyone else that
will cater to his retardedness that's
just insulting who yes I know I feel bad
for the [ __ ] community for having
compared you to them that's painful Bob
defend me uh it's not fun to make fun of
special-needs people I'm making fun of
mark that's why no that's not nice
[ __ ] you Bob he can't even stand up for
himself I don't need any of your sass I
have a YouTube channel with thousands
that was lost by thousands of subscribe
have thousands of subscribers
they're all leaving by the dozens why
why would they are we gonna be trapped
in here permanently yes how does this
work yes because I hate you Bob and
guess what we're about to die
Oh God didn't I ah no only you dick
no I have God mode apparently do you
have God mode - no I took one heart of
damage
Oh golly god mode on please that [ __ ]
[ __ ] tabulous oh where am i what am i
down here with you [ __ ] because we
blew everything up okay [ __ ] the
underwater cat underwater house I hate
the idea of a underwater house that's
just stupid
oh [ __ ] there's water yeah no kidding
Bob oh there wasn't a second ago there's
water now Bob okay I'm really confused
by the layout water get out of the water
water stupid I can't get out I'm trapped
in a weird thing I was like a personal
problem yeah it does doesn't it all
right I'm out you're not I'm really
confused by the physics of this water
the sponge is messing up with the
physics man
it's not how sponges work and that's not
how water works shut up Bob you and
minecraft things don't make sense here
that's not the point of mine okay anyway
cross water under water house off the
list we did first underwater house of
all time I know I guess just popped up
inside of all time I won I won the
underwater house no no way in hell fine
all right
my name is by the list right there I
want it okay what's next who can build
the gayest house Martin all right it's
daddy
give us some gay stuff what you know
that's awesome what not you know do you
want me to just claim that as a victory
cuz I can who can build the gas house up
one that me and we didn't even play oh
yeah that's me oh the Elector some gay
stuff what YouTube
now hold on why does pink and purple
automatically mean gay I don't know I
like purple this is magenta not purple
oh that's purple oh shut the hell up is
me mark wins i win okay so anyway John
excuse me ah there we go yeah that's
good and done I'll blow it up time to
blow it up there we go I saw a [ __ ] ah
oh my [ __ ] your iron no one gives a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you got the iron I saw you pick
it up I'm trying okay that's off the
list
okay crossed off cow so what was it haha
X is castle in the sky build a castle in
the sky I'm already working on it
doesn't look like a castle yet but just
wait see it's not even in the sky yeah
I'm working on that too I was just gonna
dig it out
I'm digging it up for you doesn't say
that it has to be high in the sky true
that this is very true
it doesn't lie what's it with your
suggestions those who are watching this
in the future also this is gonna be the
gayest castle in the sky so really
honest points hmm
wait what are you doing shut up
what does it sound like he's doing yeah
what is that
wait what is this wait you what is this
what what is this what is this mode to
be my love confession to who you well
here's what I think of your love
confession oh [ __ ]
goodbye I bet mark got his dynamite out
and blew some stuff Oh Castle is this
guy why he's got counseling this guy
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] why to the sky look
oh my
[ __ ] your cats look at that oh my god
I'm putting your name down wait
we work here such a dick Wade won the
castle in the sky with help me the big
pink pigness floating above it oh I'm I
I put my name down by yours Wade cuz I
helped Oh bullsh
alright okay okay Rex we're done with
the castle of this guy Castle this guy
is done next is cactus maze well the
[ __ ] do you get cactuses zombie desert
cactuses cactuses cactuses caucuses is
Dobby damn it
Oh Dobby please take away all of our
glass and replace it with cactus I'm
full I got to class ah
sand is appearing out nowhere what the
he gets to this [ __ ] yes it's raining
good everything characters I like it I
like it okay now we need to build a maze
um any more beer
I'm gonna build a maze in the style of
mark hello let's make the entrance to
the maze over here by this gay house yes
okay castle in the sky okay castle in
the sky this one this oh you sorry about
yours Bob
okay so helmet we want two blocks why
you can't place it on anything but sand
I forgot Oh cactus has to be placed on
sand I can't place more vile this is
terrible but I'm not going to try it I
can't place cactus right next to itself
what oh yeah that's right well that's
why a maze it's the worst maze ever
whatever came up with this idea
obviously didn't understand minecraft so
whatever
whatever this is the worst news ever
this is honestly pretty terrible blow it
up blow it up blow it up blow it up blow
to breath load up load up load up blow
it up blow this up to all this goes blow
up hey mine was amazed technically it
was not ever done
oh I'm gonna die then now it's crater ah
job
Wow you okay she broke your fall with
your own face look at all that stuff on
the ground okay I won that one okay how
the hell did you oh I just picked up all
bomb stuff dig that mean - okay now some
crap with redstone um I don't have any
red zone where's Bob ed here Bob I'm
gonna throw stuff down this hole for you
huh what what some crap with redstone
hang on you guys there yeah
okay now okay oh there's redstone
we got redstone here okay what else you
had I don't really need cactuses and
string okay so I don't like this a habit
I look at sticky pistons and sticky
pistons oh sweet we don't win we're
building some crap with redstone
we need I don't know switches we should
do something funny with redstone and
dynamite I'm gonna drink while you guys
dynamite I have an idea
oh yeah I got an idea and this is all
that's a first it's gonna be kind of
complicated
don't touch my doggy I need I need
cobblestone no I need pink wool
I need pink wool I need pink wool real
bit got magenta wool I need I need a lot
thank you I need more I need more I need
more pink wool I don't have any I need
to have I need blood purple wool more
and blue I need more there we go
all it is actually pink wool I like it
okay
all right so hey you guys do your thing
I'm gonna do my thing
now we're gonna see who wins I need more
sticky pisses no yes
I need Pam aah
what's your mark here mark what down
here huh
I don't care zombies gonna give me more
come on just disappear we go I got it I
got more okay so there we go here we go
here we go here we go you ready for this
I need I also need to switch at some
point but not right now
pop get away get away get away
Bob go good boy
Oh get Bob get away all right whatever
no you could stick around I don't care
Bob get off my Bob stop it you're
ruining everything
Bob stop it I hate you die die trick get
away I will defend myself with pink wall
that's right get away - I thought the
how do you chop wolf fast I even know
Bob get away Bob I'm trying to make some
here and you're ruining it for me all
right whatever fine fine I don't care
I need a switch there's this point I'm
helping you there's a lever okay shut up
no you're not there we go okay sticky
piston air oh that's wrong Oh fire fell
Bob stop it what I did not fell I don't
make a sticky piston go sideways I don't
know but I'm watching you from my
magical floating dirt Ford
it's not floating it's connected to the
ground shut up boy I know I know hang on
no that's not right at all yeah I gotta
get this I own I get this there we go
okay Bob stop it
vom ketonic stop it stop it stop it stop
okay all right okay we got this okay
okay good
now just leave this like ion no Bob stop
act stop
zombie kill Bob or port him so I'll do
it kill Bob
two out of three vote no bomb something
Bobby stalino nobody say zombie Ellen
you all see something really annoying
Marmite him what ah good job yeah that's
you deserve that okay so now um get this
lever here and then hit it I didn't work
at all idiot right I don't
idiot shut up fail idiot damn I need to
get more than I get this wait and are
there any more switches
nope Aaron are we allowed to have things
on P I I wanted to get a giant penis
with pumping action but it didn't work
that's not penis it did not work
apparently okay I give up on that idea
I'm not I'm not which disco okay I won
that contest I won the crap was redstone
I won that thing up here I have won
somebody screwing with me I won the
underwater house I won the who can build
the gayest house even though I didn't
build any at all congratulations mark
you're the I guess Omo of us all okay
Wade won the castle in the sky along
with me
I won the cactus maze I won the cropland
red straw hood and I wanted the diamond
I won the diamond race no one can deny
that
next is a giant chair Oh what what is
hitting me next is God are you even
paying attention even care about you you
don't give a [ __ ] do you care about the
integrity of this where's their intake
Oh what I just get ported out of my
amazingness what damn it what well I get
a hand
what is it Tyler mark but Bob why are
you texting me I pan ends up lumpy what
I just got three texts from you shad hey
Mark I don't know what I'm doing zombie
but thank you
what are you doing firing the cannon Bob
what wait wait it stopped working yes
who's firing a cannon me Oh candidate I
don't know what it's doing but I'm
firing what ha zombie is my hero zombie
can I get poured it up there that seems
awesome
everybody needs I made this place and
zombie gave me obsidian in a cannon what
everybody needs to donate the zombie
because he is the man yes what the hell
Vox something something on the
description i hope the link to the
servers in the description also yet
everywhere everybody go on and donate
and join his server because he is the
man what the hell is going on here oh
okay Bob why did you check fire and
delays are why did you text me Bob I
don't remember
oh no it's cuz I'm dead is that why
probably
you know there's a flaw with your Canon
Wade I didn't make the Canon zombied it
can't be pointed and oh you killed that
monster good job
hell yeah it can't be pointed in
different directions what the hell is
that I told you zombie made the cannon I
made the glass bowl it comes going even
farther now zombie you are the man holy
crap this is uh something else okay
you guys have fun for a bit I got aah
I'll be right no reason my terrifically
yeah zombie kick bobble okay ah get me
back to my Ken and you two be good for a
bit I'll be I'll be right back where are
you going beer yes
I didn't kill you dick
I didn't kill you either the fall might
have aah oh crap I just built gin
everywhere that's that's not good party
foul
yeah crap
I don't know what marks screen is
looking at but I guess you and I are the
only entertainment right now Bob's we
should probably talk what what mark
looking though huh what mark I relayed
your message I told them all they should
unsubscribe what the hell is happening
this is grandpa Lenovo what's going all
the bad there's gravel everywhere
I'm just spamming cannonballs and still
not hitting your targets going right
over it I can't aim this things I'll be
built it looks like a penis oh there we
go more gravel apparently well what what
Dale is happening oh yes
is beautiful I I don't even know I
currently have no frames per second got
a few but there's gravel like everywhere
I am just blowing the hell out of this
cannon no no they are did they are yeah
yeah man I can't hurt anything maybe
because there's giant piles of TNT going
everywhere where I there Oh TNT gravel
that's what I meant
oh okay
hey bomb climb on top of this gravel I
went right on I'm gonna go catch it you
catch my case Goldy Cassie fire do it
I'm trying dude break there is no try
you run ammo oh there goes ah that's
excellent that's excellent
good job good job good job
I got it oh this is the best idea ever
this is I don't know where this game
okay I'm crossing off the list as in
Wade won this one Wade thank you what I
don't know what it is but I'll take the
victory and Wade wins
Bob you're like in last place man you
haven't won a single things okay um you
say happy birthday to Jennifer happy
birthday again Jennifer okay we did that
boys you're gonna blow [ __ ] what was her
name on them chibi Fred dream
Phoebe sugar Gible Gible sugar chibi
chibi sugar see HIV I I think I think we
called her out on the last episode but
happy birthday again even though your
birthday's gonna be far over by the time
this is seen by anybody okay I won that
one I'm gonna say I won that what's that
the birthday boy yeah I won that how can
you win you're the only one that knew
that I won you guys need to keep up on
my facebook man okay I want we have
other lives
next is burned down villages and fours I
have a better idea
zombie poured us to my VIP Mike my city
Oh No poured us to my city and turn his
city into wood no no it's fine and give
us lots of flint and steel we're gonna
burn the whole [ __ ] down we're
gonna burn everything down to the ground
to everybody that put all of their heart
and soul into this town [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] you and your dreams oh he has a
backup anyway so it's fine
burn it burn it down to the ground I
don't have flint and steel
Xabi we need lots of flint and steel we
need lots of Lin steel I'm gonna go hang
out in the house okay you guys have fun
burning the troll I got even better yes
burn it all to the ground burn the books
ah my flint and steel broke booty that's
even better I'm placing TNT somebody
needs to activate it I don't have any
Flint steel left but I'm pretty sure
that one of its already on fire there we
go there we go if I blow up around our
house is it griefing yeah I'm pretty
sure it is so the flour doesn't go
anywhere oh oh I got more Flynn steel I
got more place place chocolate are we
all getting close I don't know I don't
know I hear explosions burn it down to
the ground
Bob put on your put in your voice
modulation butch one oh [ __ ]
oh yeah that one that's good
keep that one it's it's um it's sad oh I
forget the name I've totally done
professor chaos that was it
keep talking entertain people entertain
people
oh that's my flight professor chaos as I
do like I really weird chipmunk yeah
maybe that's because it really dirty
mouth you ass [ __ ]
Oh put the cells run away from explosion
holy crap I think God mode might be a
good idea for this segment I think I got
god mode I'm pretty sure hey can I pose
here anymore
no yeah give us like full inventories of
TNT and Flint steel that'd be awesome
I already got like an indie this is
awesome I was just dumping my inventory
at the moment why did I just get oak
wood stairs because that's what you want
I don't think that's deity at all
Nizam you might want to put just like
random giant piles of tea and tea
throughout yes please do please do cuz
I've said that I was gonna nuke this
nuke this entire place oh I like it
Hey look a creeper hey Here I am
No entire castle just go up yep
everything is gone
I filled every room with dynamite hahaha
and I made it so it would chain all the
way down
oh god and this map just saved okay
that's Oh God
now I'm a waitron let's blow up the
skyscraper district oh and by the end of
episode work we're all gonna run down
the hallway of doom whatever I called it
zombie we tlg everywhere in the
skyscraper discrete everywhere zombie
please wait there we go
that's it that's it that's it that's
what I'm talking about oh man and if
you're if you guys are drunk like us and
weren't listening you need to you need
to donate the zombies server cuz he's
awesome
yeah is he's like the best ever oh man
this is the best mod of all time oh my
god
yeah LG boaters you can't look at you
here's looking at this oh shut up
ha ha ha guys it was lag Oh God
oh this is my house I'm blowin up true
dat
your skyscraper you mean oh [ __ ] ah so
much good stuff oh it's so sad yeah it's
all gonna die okay yeah well we do this
when we do more episodes we got actually
like do objectives or something
sup arm we're gonna do the drunk
interferes with the objectives there's
like custom maps that we could do or
something or something I've just stole
everything from me hey hey look at have
you guys seen my giant statue of me no
yes I don't know hello hello hi Bob what
are you doing it's trying to kill me but
he sucks he stole all my stuff
whoa happen oh and I told me I don't
think I'm gonna survive we only got like
five minutes left on this episode do
something um something I don't know well
we got six minutes we got six minutes to
do something what I'll go I'm out of
here [ __ ] dammit
well fine [ __ ] you guys out zombie TNT
all in the residential district TT
everywhere you guys aren't going to help
me I'm just gonna blow everything up oh
I'm working the entire ground is blown
up I can't get to the residential I
think I just fell into a glitch more
zombie more more more more zombie MA oh
god this is gonna give me so many
subscribers you know
except for all the people that worked
hard on it shut up they they they knew
it was coming they knew what they signed
up for I just blew up my own okay here
we go
oh good lordy ah might have been a bit
excessive
oh oh yeah possessive when you're
boiling up everything you've ever boy I
got blown down to the Coliseum haha up I
think I just got kick I've been the
server crashed good I think
yep I'm pretty sure Oh God
yep okay and my fraps cut out to my old
my minecraft crashed my whole pie graph
crashed
okay and now now we're recording again
so alright yeah that happened okay now
they can hear you zombie still on our
Skype call yes he is
alright good Bobby would you watch this
I'm back in the game on YouTube
who would watch this is nonsense who
would guess is the question hmm oh man
my poor my poor zombie one of your
subscribers on YouTube mark I don't know
it's hard to track keep track of
individuals subscribes when you have
thousands all crap has a little more T&T
I know I found it good job there yes and
Sonic eight for me please no don't do it
I have 40 stacks of flint and steel
where's Marc's chairs that bone up
already I think it's our Ben blah blah
blown up a long time ago actually I
found part of it that you wanted me to
light that on fire for you
oh hell follow me up to the up to the
castle on the hill
we got to go up to um up top and follow
me follow me well I just jumped in the
water to say hello me cuz my statue is
still here and it deserves to be taken
down I've never seen your statue it's
hard to miss it's gigantic hey could I
get ported to wherever you're at the
markiplier meetup area I don't know how
to get there from this oh I forgot about
my my watermelon patch you guys haven't
seen my watermelon patch I think I found
the entrance to your mind I can't find
out how to get up to where you're
actually a I fine [ __ ] it [ __ ] it then
we're almost out of time anyway I just
good here I'm gonna blow up my way up
there actually the statue should remain
nothing should happen this statue just
be statue hanging over devastation cuz
that's awesome
it's kind of how you are pretty much I
destroy everything I touch hey bye now
ow ah I died
ha ha ha [ __ ] well your fall with
your own face ok fine last thing we're
gonna blow up is my watermelon patch
because [ __ ] watermelons there's that
big a bad kid you know you know who you
are your watermelons where's that at
it's some hand zombie can we get ported
to the watermelon patch I know this ya
poured us all to the watermelon I was
like 10 feet away but we're lazy and
you're an admin
your name is still gonna be floating in
the sky Margaret's gonna be all that's
left when we're done here and the statue
did you say I'm gonna find it and blow
it up look up in the sky and you'll see
it I see it I'm gonna go blow it all
don't blow it up zombie don't let him
blow it up it's my step it up I'll blow
them up
don't blow yeah why are we getting where
are we in a grave oh I have a flint in
stone no [ __ ] you I owe you I get a
frames per second you guys are both
running in the TNT Exorcist
all I can see is boxes of TNT everywhere
every slice is a giant thing of water
every single watermelon got replaced
with TNT there that was awesome and
actually we are out of time that is it
Oh oh man anyway social guard
devastation job did my outro thank you
everybody so much sitting shut up sorry
hope y'all I was going to do it shut up
hope y'all have been awaiting ba ba with
Mark is a special guest ah okay thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you like what you saw please let us know
in the comments like what you like and
if you have suggestions for future drunk
minecraft episodes please let us know in
the comments or on my facebook or
whatever o do all that stuff so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always we'll see you in the next
video bye bye bye bye everybody bye ah
bye bye bye bye bye now